what is an entrepreneur
and can you learn to be one or does it
have to be in your dna
when you were born it was in my dna when
sometime i was a young kid i always knew
i was going to start companies but can
you learn it if you're not born with
that gene
this is the age-old question you've
raised it is the most important question
can you teach entrepreneurship
i've tried to answer that question over
the years i've tried to identify
entrepreneurs in my classes that i teach
i believe
that what works and what makes someone
an entrepreneur
is
a burning desire to be free
it's not about the greed of money it's
the pursuit of personal freedom and so
when i meet people that have a burning
desire to be free then i know i i'm
working with an entrepreneur because
you may try five or six different ideas
and they may all fail but the fact that
you keep going back and trying again is
that burning desire and i don't think
you can teach that you either have that
desire you don't and it's only present
in about a third of the population in in
every country it's the same you find
two-thirds of the people work for the
other third and of that third ten
percent are remarkably successful
and so you know it's sort of
if you think about it it's a very small
fraction of people that that change the
destiny of an of an economy
um with you know profound
businesses that grow and grow and grow
because they're very successful at
solving someone's problem but the the
motivation they have is that to pursue
personal freedom you will find that in
today's modern entrepreneurs elon musk
for example
look at look at what that man's achieved
and he's just getting going and so he
has a burning desire to do things his
way my son works for him at tesla the
company has a remarkable culture of
getting stuff done i met with a lot of
venture capitalists over the years we
funded around 90 companies in 20 years i
have my own list of things
of what i look for when i'm considering
funding somebody what do you look for in
an entrepreneur when someone comes in
and pitches to you
i look for the ability to pivot because
whatever idea they have is probably
going to fail or that's going to have to
be changed you always start with the
optimism of the idea but i look at the
entrepreneur and say
does this man or woman have the ability
if things do not work out to pivot to
change so that all this capital isn't
lost
and i'm pretty good now at determining
winners and losers i mean
you know that's what makes me successful
as an investor i don't get it right all
the time
but i certainly have been successful and
i'll let you in a little secret about 70
of my success over the last decade
now it's more it's more like 12 years
has been with women entrepreneurs
which 70 percent of the really good
outcomes have been managed by women and
i think
you know i have a theory about it they
mitigate risk very well
they focus on return of capital first
not on capital
um
and that old adage you want something
done give it to a busy mother is true
for a lot of women they can judge and
balance a lot of things at the same time
and so i'm a little biased now if you
look at the deal flow
and i do a lot of deals we have
currently we just closed another one
last week we have 35 portfolio companies
right now
that's a lot for any venture firm
but i have the benefit of social media
so that i i'm able to help them reduce
their customer acquisition costs in an
incredible way
and so that that's sort of our secret
sauce in my venture firm i i basically
go work for these people to help get
their story out reduce their capital
costs and their customer acquisition
costs
and uh and in exchange i get very
proprietary deals
and i know what my value is so so this
model really works for me but i really
look for that ability to pivot because
you know and i don't have to tell you
this you're going to go through a lot of
hills and valleys
before the deal's done
what's your investment strategy as a
whole we're watching shark tank i see
you invest in all kinds of businesses
now on that show obviously you don't
know what's coming i mean you've
invested in
from a to z non-related you have your
venture from what are you looking for
in terms of a strategy is there one or
do you just take every deal
kind of one-off and you look at every
specific situation well i have deals in
all 11 sectors of the economy including
real estate i mean
i am not driven by just one sector you
know some people just do biotech some do
pharma some do manufacturing
i go everywhere and lately i've been
doing a lot of work in crypto and
decentralized finance and
right we're going to get to that and
yeah yeah
it's sort of um
a multi-sectoral i look for that
entrepreneur that woman or man that's
going to drive the the process
i look for structure um in terms of how
i mean the big the the challenge i have
is
i know my value and so not to be
arrogant but when people come to me and
say look um
we're doing a round at a you know
10 million valuation or 25 million
valuation and we're closing it there's a
million left
i have no interest in doing that you're
you're tr you want to put my name on
your cap table we both know why you want
to do that i get it
but that's not a deal i'd ever do i am
not like any of your other investors
if you want me as an investor you have
to make me a founder which means you're
going to give me
founding shares of the company for free
now a lot of people choke when they hear
this but then hear me out i say and
here's what i'll do
i don't care how many rounds you've
raised after we agree on the founders
shares that i'm going to take from you
you're going to give me for free
i'm going to parry pursue my percentage
ownership into every round you've ever
raised at that price so if you did
around at five million valuation i'll
give you cash
for my
seven percent of the ownership i
generally don't do this
i start i ask for nine point nine
percent of 500 shares so i'm not an
insider and you don't want me as an
insider because social media is what's
so valuable i have to be able to speak
about why i invested in it so i don't
join the boards
um
and then i then i invest in every round
for for my 9.9 percent
50 of the companies absolutely choke
when they hear this they say why would
we ever do that and they don't the other
half do and the reason they do it is i
simply let them talk to my ceos i don't
sell myself i let my ceos sell myself
they do the work they explain how my
organization
changes their path and makes them far
more successful in raising capital at a
lower cost
because now there's a direct correlation
between social media and market cap i
mean you've seen it in reddit you've
seen it in robinhood you've seen it on
meme stocks
it's very powerful and i i know it's a
fact
and then i help them with customer
acquisition there isn't a single
retailer on earth that won't return my
call that's one of the great things
about being a shark right at the
president or ceo level
we can do a lot of things together but i
don't do it for free and obviously
that gives me a huge advantage against
just some random vc
does it make sense to put all of your
money or most of your money into the s p
500
given that there are probably less than
five investors in the entire world who
have beaten it over the last 30 years
and the chance of the next warren
buffett showing up at your door in
topeka kansas or wherever you're living
is way less than getting struck by the
odds of
lightning which by the way is one in
seven hundred thousand
yeah i mean you know i do have trusts
they do invest in the s p 500 i do i i
do own or i'm a half owner of an
indexing company that services pension
plans
and sovereign wealth and uh you know
state
funds and everything else so we design
derivatives of the s p 500 and i invest
in those that tend to be a little higher
quality i don't want to own every every
company in in the s p 500 i mean the
airlines are uninvestable now their
balance sheets are upside down after
pandemic i think united had something
like 8 billion of debt now it's got 23
billion it happened in 18 months i would
never own that that's just a speculation
now so you know there's certain rules i
have but that's way different than
investing in private companies and being
a venture capitalist i mean
the majority of of the money i make is
not from the indexes i i'm the majority
the money i make is from bets i i make
on men and women that i invest in
and that you know
for example
three years ago
someone came to me in florida and said
um
would you like to be an investor in lsd
and i said no that's an illegal schedule
on narcotic and he said no no i'm going
to do fda trials towards turning it into
a medicine
i thought that was pretty crazy
that was mine met i think you know i
bought into that when it had a valuation
of 10 million dollars and
it's trading in a billion and a half now
and i was a you know founding
shareholder of that there's all kinds of
research going on in the space and in
fact there's many other companies that
have pursued it we were the founders of
that whole space and we're the first to
ever do it
uh the same thing with um recent
investments are in wonderfuy a company
that is doing decentralized finance
uh in a very uh on an app so to to to
democratize it for for people that can't
understand the complexity of of staking
and loaning and all the things you have
to do to to use defy
just bought a piece of immune holdings a
company that owns nft.com
and is building out the nft platforms
there a large piece of it so i'm very
involved in that space i'm intrigued by
the magic of what happens
when you when you put capital to work
with with a with a strong leader
and and just watch it blossom like a
flower it's just incredible and all the
twists and turns that occur
i give them advice i can um i help them
with social media obviously and i help
them with customer acquisition
um
but generally it's it's them it's them
it's their idea and
my my my money is just
uh you know gasoline on their fire i
want to ask you about the expression
that failure is not an option
is that right is it okay to fail
and going one step further some failure
a good thing what's your advice to
people for example have been fired once
or multiple times or those who've
started a company or fail or multiple
companies that have failed or if you're
one of the 1.5 million people who
declare bankruptcy every year and you
want to start a company
failure is actually very important in
the journey of any entrepreneur
i i prefer not to invest in people that
have never experienced it
i prefer to invest in an entrepreneur
that's failed two or three times
and understands why they failed that
experience is very important and very
motivating
i have failed many times i've made very
bad investments and
lost lots lots lots and lots of money
but also made lots of money i mean it is
you are not going to have a perfect
track record no one will
particularly investing in venture i mean
that's so risky in itself anyways
there are some rules though you know
it's important to understand why you
failed
if you know i'm talking to an
entrepreneur and they're telling me
about you know something that didn't
work out and they can't explain to me
why it didn't work out
then i won't invest with them because
they haven't learned anything they just
have failed
so i would say failure is an option a
very good option to make you better as
an entrepreneur
entrepreneurs hate to fail
so when they start the next journey they
try even harder
and unfortunately
and i say this to my graduating cohorts
there is no life balance for an
entrepreneur the whole idea is you
sacrifice your early years
to have freedom in your later years
that's the whole idea unfortunately you
find out in your later years you want to
even work harder because all you know is
work and you do sacrifice a lot of
family time you don't go to picnics you
don't go to soccer games you're not free
on the weekends
i'll tell you a story
about a class i was teaching a few years
ago a night class
it started at six
and went till nine o'clock as these do
and this was a big cohort i mean it must
have had
300 people in it it was a very big room
microphones cameras you know big
speakers and and screens so they could
see you down at the bottom
and um
at the end of the class like five
minutes before nine
this this fellow at the back raises his
hand and he says
you know
can i ask you a question and i said sure
you haven't said you haven't contributed
anything to this class you haven't said
a thing in three hours so
you know welcome to ask a question i
said cynically to him because he hadn't
said anything
basically the story was this
he was in his
graduating year of engineering
electrical engineering
and he was also a coder
he was also
he could write code and he had designed
a compliance cloud-based platform for
hedge funds of 250 million and under so
he found that niche market it was a
royalty based system he did all the mark
to market compliance so they could be
compliant in their reporting to the
regulator
and
he was able to acquire his customers
just by word of mouth
he was at the run rate
was five million dollars of free cash
flow a year while he was in his dorm
so he says to me my girlfriend came to
me today and said i have to make a
decision i said what's the decision well
we're engaged but she doesn't want to
live this way i have no time for her
family i have no time for her i work
every weekend i work all night and i'm
running this business and i'm trying to
graduate from engineering and the guy's
at the top of his class and also
he's very gifted
what do i do
she's she i don't want to lose her
but she's going to walk out on me if i
don't change
and i said
which one
is easier to replace
your business that you've worked for
three years to build is now generating
five million of free cash flow
or your fiance
and
a lot of people didn't like that answer
and he said well what do you think i
said i think she's the wrong person for
you
i'm not dr phil here
but you're an entrepreneur a successful
one there isn't a woman in this class
that wouldn't want to date you next week
you're a good looking guy you have five
million dollars i think you can find
someone else that understands your
journey
entrepreneurs need to understand that
their partner has to understand them was
my point
anyways that class was a [ __ ] show it
didn't end until 10 o'clock as we
debated this whole thing
from what i understand he's he's has a
family he's very happy but not with that
woman
so maybe i did something right that
night
you have people who are buying
eight-second video clips of lebron james
dunks for six hundred thousand 000 it's
an nft
frenzy out there and you and the best
venture capital firms in the world are
backing them calling them
this calling this the next big thing
what are your thoughts on people
and non-fungible tokens and all of this
and is it going to be like the early.com
days that i was a part of
where so many of your friends were a
part of and you were probably a part of
where the frenzy's going to die down and
investors lost tens of billions of
dollars and more than 95 of these
companies are going to crash and burn
no it's different even though you can go
online right now and look at it on your
computer screen you don't actually own
it the ownership is the person that owns
the nft with the smart contract built
into the ethereum blockchain and so that
has tremendous value
where i think the most interesting
market is and where i'm going and where
i'm investing in nfts is where you can
tie a physical asset that has already
proven itself in the physical world
to the digital nft world and the example
i'm going to give you is the watch
industry there's so many people that
want to have my nft of my steel white
face daytona that i wore for 13 years on
shark tank
or my one of a kind ming
they'll never own the watch
but they'd love to buy the nft of that
watch and so we know what the watch is
worth in the physical world and we'll
find out through the auction and the cry
of price discovery on the nft world and
so i'm working very hard to create the
standards along with the horological
societies in new york
to determine what the protocol is going
to be for all watch nfts everywhere one
idea is to do this if you allow us to
make the nft at the point of origination
in other words when the watch first
leaves
the factory that piece forever will pay
your royalty every time it trades hands
in perpetuity while it remains
a piece
so in other words
you know if you're if you're a very
unique watchmaker and you're only making
13 or 14 watches each year
you'll start building a revenue stream
even after you stop making watches
because you'll be in the smart contract
and your estate will be paid a royalty
every time the watch trades
that's the likely outcome
because
the watch industry cannot make enough
watches to fulfill the demand anymore
for watches particularly brands like
adam rpk rolex
patek philippe fp jorn ming they simply
can't that if you if you order one of
those watches you might wait two years
before you get it if you ever get it and
so
the nft market will fill up the slack
for those who really want to own the
dials in a different way and and i'm a
believer we'll find out we're going to
learn so much in the next 24 months it's
such an exciting time to be investing in
digital
and i'm i think it's terrific and very
exciting and i think has tremendous
upside potential there's no question
about it if you like that video where
did you see my next one don't forget to
click right over here and subscribe